Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
This is Luke Beasley filling in for David today
while he's away on paternity leave. If you like
what you're seeing, definitely go check me out
on YouTube. I have my own show. It's called The
Luke Beasley Show. But you can just search Luke
Beasley on YouTube and you will find it. Lots
of good stuff going down there. So before we
get into this next story, I want to warn you,
it's absolutely horrifying and heartbreaking.
An 11 year old girl who survived the day shooting.
Spoke to Congress, testified in front of Congress.
About how she watched her teacher. She watched
her friend get killed by the gunman. Who went
into that school in your body? Rob Elementary. And
one of the stories you may have heard that's just
absolutely horrifying is. She was afraid after the
gunman had gone through her friend, her teacher,
that he was going to come back around and shoot
her and sort of make it look like she had already
been shot. She put her hand in the blood of her
friend. And smeared all over her so that she
would look like she was also all bloodied up and
and had been hit. Let's watch a few moments from
this testimony and then we'll discuss.
Speaker 3: There's a door between our
classroom, the window, and then
we went to the other classroom.
And then she went. There's a door between our
classrooms and he was there. And so my teacher
told me that she drank and I shot her in the
head. And then he shot. Some of my classmates
in the light force pulled over to the
backs of he shot friend knows them to me
and I saw you didn't come back to the room
like I would like it all on alone and.
What did you do then when you put the loan on
yourself? You stayed quiet. And then I go with
teachers from the country. What are you telling
anyone else? I told her that we need help. And
she said the police to her classroom. Right. Or
things that you want different. What would it mean
to her school to feel safe at school when
I don't want it to happen again? Do
you think it's going to happen again?
Speaker 1: The entire story is. I mean, there's
words heartbreaking, but you can't describe.
The level of of wrong that that is
no 11 year old should have to recount
an experience like that. No person, obviously. But
when you see it coming from an 11 year old girl,
it's just incomprehensible. No kids should go
to school, afraid that they might get shot.
That's not something in a civilized,
developed country. That should happen.
I know you've all seen these numbers before, but
I'm going to throw up a graphic of the United
States gun violence compared to other countries.
We stand a way apart. Something's wrong.
And we hear all the time from anti-gun reform
advocates. There's all these other things.
Oh, it's no, it's mental health. It's violent
video games. It's the security of the schools.
And while I want to address those, too,
let's look into how we can make schools safe
and secure. Let's look in to mental
health issues in the country. Of course,
I want to discuss that. But we
can't ignore the massive obvious.
In our face issue, which is. Gun laws. Other
countries have all of these other areas that
they also have issues with. Mental health is a
great example that lots of other countries are
dealing with mental health problems, but their gun
violence is nothing compared to the United States,
and that is because we don't regulate guns
in a commonsense way. We're not talking about
taking away your Second Amendment nothing.
We're talking about doing very common sense
regulations and laws that will
protect lives, undeniably.
Now, a lot of times when we discuss this,
people will say, I hear liberals say common
sense a lot. What do they mean by that? So
let's just go through four big main easy,
very popular among the country type
policies that we could implement.
Universal background checks, red flag laws,
raising the age to purchase these weapons
and waiting periods. And that would in
many of the past cases, we've sort of
seen make a difference and it would prevent
future things from happening going forward.
It just doesn't make any sense why everyone
want to be on board with this. And polling shows
actual Americans are on board with this. But
then for some reason, Republican politicians
specifically are standing in the way of doing
anything. And I've heard a lot of people witness
after witnessing these horrible tragedies
and then the inaction by the people in power.
I've heard people express the sentiment of there's
no hope. It's impossible. I kind of give up.
We see time and time again horrible things happen
that you would think would wake every single
person in power up. But it doesn't. And I just
want to say, while I totally empathize with that,
it is enraging, watching those people who are
supposed to solve issues like this in our country
not do it. And and you do have those
moments where you're like, if it hasn't
happened in the past, with all the tragedies
we've seen, why is something going to change now?
But I do think 11 year old girls
like the one we just watched. And
all of the young people we've seen, all of the
other innocent lives that have been lost in.
Mass shootings. They all deserve us to not
give up. They at least deserve that from us.
We can't singlehandedly make this happen.
But the one thing we can dedicate to each
one of those lost lives and each one of the
people like the one we just watched, who are
forever traumatized by an event like this. Is to
not give up. We can at least give that to them.
And so while it's going to look impossible many
days, I beg each one of you, because this is what
causes change to happen, to not give up, to keep
pushing everything you can possibly do to keep
this issue on the front of mind of the
politicians and of Americans broadly.